un moment il ya un détail qui rend la
faire encore plus terrible qu'elle ne
peut l'être vous c'est quand vous
réalisez que céline quand vous avez été
à pas pour un des rapts et vous vous
dites à un moment vous avez été témoin
d'un des meurtres de votre père le
meurtre d'une jeune fille dans un bois
vous avez assisté à cela
j'étais très jeune oui c'est le décalage
je devais avoir 10 11 ans je crois ou
dit oui je n'avais pas fait ma communion
donc donc vous étiez en âge de
comprendre absolument ce qui se passait
oui comment se fait-il que vous ayez été
sur la scène de ce crime mes parents
travailler à des postes différents elles
matin à l'après midi donc les jours de
vacances ou ou de repos hebdomadaire
émile nous gardait l'après midi ou le
matin peu importe
et je me souviens qu'un soir nous avions
pris en charge une jeune femme dont je
n'ai pas vu le visage ça c'était à saint
florentin
elle avait un foulard sur la tête comme
ça se faisait dans les années 60 et donc
il nous a dit restez dans la voiture je
vais raccompagné je ne souvient pas du
nom je sais même pas s'il l'a dit et mes
frères pleurer ils sont plus jeunes que
moi donc
pourtant je n'étais pas très courageuse
je suis descendu par un petit à lui
parce que je ne trouvais pas de chemin
et je les trouvais voilà et vous avez dû
vivre avec ça le reste de votre vie
belle ce traumatisme un enfant dans
pendant quelques temps je me suis dit
que c'était pas réel et puis chose
étonnante ce qu'emile louis qui ne
faisait jamais rien dans la maison
c'était bien chargé de mettre tout de
suite ses vêtements dans la machine à
laver et il m'a dit attention ce que tu
as vu m
même sort pour un enfant la mère oui et
menacent d'imposer à prendre pour un
enfant c'est quelque chose de terrible
inimaginable imaginables on enlève sa
mère un piège était à l'époque très
attaché